I want to watch something suspenseful
but not in the mood for straight-up
horror Netflix has you covered the
streaming service has quite a few
thrillers that'll get your adrenaline
going and send a shiver up your spine
but instead of watching some of the more
mainstream movies online why not check
out something a little more obscure
how about backcountry flight deliverance
or The Blair Witch Project before it
that country will make you think twice
before taking a walk in the woods like
it's for bears the 2015 flick features
folks who decide to spend a weekend in
the forest even though there are
certified city slickers where the car
why would you do that and want you on
that angle right here soon the two find
themselves map 'let's phoneless and lost
in the woods and it doesn't help matters
knowing there's another hiker nearby who
seems kind of dangerous but really he's
the least of their problems considering
they're also being stalked by a
man-eating black bear blue capris on
October 2nd 2002 a man was shot to death
in the parking lot of a Maryland grocery
store it was the first killing in a
three-week long murder spree that would
claimed 10 lives in the Washington DC
area the terror came to an end when
police arrested two snipers had been
shooting their way across the US for
month leaving a total of 17 bodies in
their wake 2013 ripped from the
headlines blue Caprice takes place in
the months leading up to the shooting
focusing on a twisted relationship
between the snipers John Allen Muhammad
and Lee Boyd Malvo abandoned by his
mother the teenage Malvo gravitates
toward them in the field of Muhammad who
takes the boy under his wing but in
exchange for a father figure of Malvo
agrees to help Muhammad enact his
homicidal plan
[Music]
cold and July it starts off like a
typical revenge flick about a man caught
in the crosshairs of an angry ex-con but
about midway through 2014 cold in July
takes such a hard left turn that it
becomes a completely different beef but
you have any marriage on this damned
Pinto you know how to use it it's gotta
pay for it we could split it richard
dane played by dexter's michael c hall
is in a tricky situation after
accidentally killing a burglar was
broken into his home things get worse
when he discovers that the curse dad is
one bad dude at first cold in July plays
like a cat-and-mouse game between the
two but our hero soon realizes there's a
conspiracy afoot and he's only a pawn in
a much larger scheme the double if
you're a fan of Jesse Eisenberg well
2013's the double is definitely the
movie for you it's got two Eisenberg for
the price of one based on the novella by
Dostoyevsky the double follows a young
office worker named Simon James a guy
beaten down by the system he's nervous
shy and ignored by everyone including
Hannah the girl of his dreams and all
the creepy guys who are Daniel
it could be guys it's like it's turned
upside down when a man named James Simon
becomes his co-worker James is Simon's
exact opposite in almost every way Simon
is introverted while James is outgoing
Simon is full of self-doubt whereas
James is confidence personified of
course the two men do share one eerie
similarity they look exactly alike a
fact that no one else seems to notice
unfortunately the creepy resemblance
allows James to completely invade
Simon's life but everybody's got a
breaking point and Simon eventually
decides it's time to scan this ground
whatever the consequences these guys I
say you need to leave now
you go okay
frailty the late great actor Bill Paxton
also dabbled in directing with the 2005
golfing flick starring Shia LaBeouf
called the greatest game ever played and
the 2001 thriller frailty a terrifying
portrait of religion gone wrong the
dances on the fine line between thriller
and horror in addition to calling the
chef behind the camera Paxton also
played a loving father who becomes an
axe murderer after God supposedly orders
him to rid the world of demons demons
that look like humans but he isn't going
to fight the forces of evil by himself
believing he's a truly divine warrior he
recruits his two sons one who's totally
on board and another who thinks that dad
has gone mad
we don't fear these teams we destroy
them we pick them up one by one and we
pitch them out of this world while
ultimately more thriller than or be
warned the film does involve a lot of
head shopping body burying and
disturbing scenes of child abuse with
God's ru and you can't escape God's
wrath
the imposter a true story of a creepy
con man that will leave your mind
reeling when the credits start to roll
2012's the imposter is a rare
documentary that also works as a
pulse-pounding thriller I didn't give a
damn what other people were thinking and
what they were feeling I care about
myself
the less you know about the part
documentary part stage thriller the
better but here's a taste the impostor
tells the story of a French criminal who
posed as a missing Texas teen and
convinced the boy's family that he was a
long-lost relative even though he was
too old had a French accent and the
wrong hair and eye color how you'll have
to watch and find out story so bizarre
it's hard to believe it's true seriously
the invitation we've all been invited to
some pretty weird parties but none
compared to the ultra creepy affair in
2016 the invitation it all starts when
quiet brooding will shows up for a
dinner at his ex-wife's house she's back
in the states after getting remarried in
Mexico and wants to get together with
the old gang including will who is still
struggling with the loss of her son so
maybe that's why will starts acting so
strangely once he arrives at the party
or maybe there's something rotten going
on in the Hollywood Hills we chose you
because you managed not be chosen to be
here tonight after all why are there
bars in all the windows why is the front
door locked at the evening unwinds will
find himself battling a sneaking
suspicion that something terrible is
about to happen all while battling his
own emotional breakdown We Need to Talk
About Kevin the 2011 domestic thriller
we need to talk about kevin focuses on
Tilda Swinton's Ava and her son Kevin to
say they don't get along would be an
understatement I don't give a rat Kevin
is an absolute monster a budding
psychopath who charms the world into
thinking as a normal kid but when he's
alone with his mom that's when we see
the team's true sadistic side a darkness
has been growing ever since Kevin was an
infant and finally once you've sucked up
an entire bottle of wine you can go all
gooey hide and say how nice it is to
spend quality time together
his downward spiral divides Ava and her
husband as it becomes increasingly clear
what Kevin is truly capable of there is
no point that's the point thanks for
watching click the looper icon a
subscribe to our YouTube channel plus
check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love to
[Music]